Jean-Marc Reynaud bonjour c'est
aujourd'hui que les travaux pour la
construction d'une retenue d'eau qu'on
appelle aussi une méga bassine doivent
reprendre à Sainte Soline dans les
Deux-Sèvres après des violences
manifestations du week-end dernier les
opposants au projet ont prévu de se
rendre à nouveau sur place aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous redoutez de nouveau
débordements bah écoutez comme comment
on l'a vu ce week-end même si c'était
une minorité de d'autres militants ont
été plus pacifiques on a constaté comme
ce week-end un certain nombre d'actes de
violences à l'endroit en particulier des
forces de l'ordre que je veux saluer
saluer parce qu'elles ont été soumises à
rue des preuves une soixantaine de
blessés une soixantaine de blessés les
images parlent d'elles-mêmes sur les
attitudes d'un certain nombre de
manifestants donc forcément on redoute
ce genre de moments et en même temps le
sous l'égide de la préfète qui a fait un
travail remarquable faire en sorte que
force reste à la loi puisque c'est un
projet qui est autorisé qui a passé
toutes les étapes des autorisations
et qui sur bien des domaines est un
projet vertueux parce qu'il engage les
agriculteurs à mieux raisonner leur
cycle de l'eau donc j'espère que la
raison l'emportera l'un des reproches
que font les adversaires de ce type de
projet de retenue d'eau c'est que ça ne
prend pas en compte la nécessité au fond
de changer notre type de production
agricole notre agriculture au sens large
même pour s'adapter aux changements
climatique est-ce que cet argument est
recevable mais c'est exactement
l'inverse en fait parce que ce projet il
vise à tenir compte d'un cycle de l'eau
qui est devenu arythmique qui va être de
plus en plus arithmique la quantité
d'eau qui va tomber sur sur le sol des
Deux-Sèvres comme par tout en France
c'est à peu près la même l'idée c'est
simplement de prélever l'eau au moment
où elle est la plus prélevable
c'est-à-dire en hiver et en nous fin
d'automne début d'hiver pour faire en
sorte qu'on n'est pas besoin de prélever
l'eau au moment où on en a besoin pour
l'agriculture mais au moment où elle est
plus rare c'est-à-dire en été donc ce
projet là est visa évitez qu'on fasse
qu'on fasse de quelle situation on part
on parle aujourd'hui d'une situation où
il y a une grande partie de l'eau qui
est prélevée par voie de forage dans la
période estivale qui est la période la
plus tendue y compris pour l'eau potable
y compris pour l'autre les tiages des
cours d'eau et c'était tous ces éléments
sont des éléments importants et donc
premier élément c'est un un projet qui
vise ce sont des projets qui visent à
mieux utiliser l'eau dans les périodes
et mieux la prélever dans les périodes
où il y en a suffisamment pour pas dire
trop d'une certaine façon deuxième
élément il y a un engagement des des
agriculteurs à un volume d'eau qui est
moins important en termes de prélèvement
et qui sera contrôlé par l'État et puis
troisième élément les engagements qui
sont pris sur la réduction d'un certain
nombre de produits phytosanitaires c'est
un débat important puisqu'il faut que
nous soyons sur cette trajectoire là et
donc sur plein de points de vue
d'ailleurs ça a été dit par toutes les
études c'est un projet qui montre la
volonté de mieux gérer l'eau et de mieux
gérer les produits phytosanitaires les
coûts d'éclat de groupe ou de
groupuscules écologistes se multiplient
depuis quelques jours en France et
ordonne le monde on boit maintenant la
mode du collage les militants se collent
des voitures à des statues
à des murs de musées
cette mobilisation on l'a vu après une
forme particulièrement violente à
Sainte-Soline dans le Deux-Sèvres est-ce
que vous croyez que nous soyons entrés
dans une nouvelle ère du combat
écologiste une aire au fond violente
mais c'est un peu la crainte que j'ai
c'est pour ça que je le dénonce que je
pense que le combat pour le combat
écologiste est un combat qui est saint
et à vrai dire dans les années 70 ou 80
et un certain nombre de figures
écologistes ont porté des combats qui
n'ont pas été inutiles mais dès lors que
vient s'introduire la question de la
violence et du non-respect des règles et
des lois vous voyez bien que dans
l'opinion publique vous pose vous poser
un problème qui est celui de la
légitimité des actions et donc je pense
que ça nuit à la cause pour tout vous
dire parce que si vous ouvrez la boîte
du fait que on peut s'abstraire des
règles de droit ceux qui sont les
opposants à tel ou tel action vont
pouvoir eux aussi s'abstraire des règles
de droit ceux qui voudraient créer tel
ou tel réserve d'eau en s'abstrayant des
règles de droit ceux qui voudrait ne pas
respecter les normes de tel ou tel
projet donc ou de tel ou telle produit
et donc en vous commencez à vous dire
est-ce qu'on appelle sous le concept
mais qui est fallacieux pour moi de
désobéissance civile
vous introduisez l'idée que la loi n'est
pas le l'élément supérieur
vous aurez des gens qui vous
expliqueront que ils ont le droit qu'ils
vont faire des forages ça existe dans
certains pays sauvages parce que après
tout la cause supérieure c'est la cause
supérieure qui est la leur et pas la
cause supérieure de l'intérêt général et
donc je trouve que ce glisser dans ces
interstices là qui est celui de ma cause
est supérieure au reste de l'intérêt
général et de ce point de vue là je peux
m'abstraire des règles de droit et à la
vérité un certain nombre d'entre eux
sont parlementaire à quoi ça sert de
voter la loi si on passe son temps le
week-end à dire qu'il ne faut pas la
respecter donc poser le principe du
respect de la loi c'est un principe pour
moi essentiel est-ce que vous parleriez
comme l'a fait le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin déco
terrorisme il en il emploie les mots qui
sont les siens mais à la vérité quand
vous regardez les actions
bonnes raisons simples il me semble que
ça peut ça peut faire écho pour dire les
choses très clairement parce que je
trouve que cette manière
de venir en masse pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux avec une volonté simple qui
est une volonté de violence et moi j'ai
eu d'un certain nombre d'agriculteurs
dans ces territoire là qui craignait y
compris pour leur propre sécurité et de
ce point de vue là les mots qu'on doit
Gérald Darmanin ne sont pas faux alors
je ne fais pas d'amalgame entre toutes
les formes d'action et des formes
d'action pacifistes mais ce que j'ai vu
ce week-end c'est des gens qui
essayaient de répondre à travers les
champs à travers parfois la menace ou le
risque de menace sur un certain nombre
de biens et de personnes des menaces qui
sont de cet ordre là vous êtes marc-edo
le ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire d'ailleurs les
intitulés des ministères sont
particulièrement travaillées
est-ce que la France a les moyens de
bâtir une plaine et entière souveraineté
alimentaire elle a les moyens de le
faire sous réserve que nous nous
inscrivions résolument de ce que sont
les grands dérèglements du monde des
règlements climatiques règlement
géopolitique parfois des règlements
économiques nous sommes souverains sur
des grandes productions que sont le lait
et les grandes cultures en particulier
les céréales en revanche nous avons
besoin de reconquérir une souveraineté
par exemple je pense aux fruits et
légumes on a lancé un plan souveraineté
qui va viser à retrouver la souveraineté
que nous avons perdue puisque 50 % des
fruits et légumes consommés en France ne
viennent pas de producteurs français et
donc les moyens c'est des moyens
d'investissement l'innovation et la
recherche la capacité d'adaptation qu'on
va donner et qu'il faut donner aux
agriculteurs est-ce que tout ça n'est
pas sain pour leur donner la capacité à
continuer à produire la question de
l'accès à l'eau est un élément essentiel
il y a beaucoup de maraîchers cette
année qui sont trouvés dans la situation
de ne pas pouvoir produire parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas l'accès à l'eau donc il
faut qu'on les mette en situation par la
soutien l'investissement par le soutien
à l'innovation de pouvoir se confronter
à la souveraineté parce que
l'alimentation la vue encore ce week-end
avec les décisions de Monsieur Poutine
ça te redevient une arme est-ce qu'on
peut craindre des
manques voire des pénuries de produits
alimentaires dans les mois qui viennent
non fondamentalement non le risque
simplement justement il y a des
producteurs il y a la capacité à
produire le risque principal c'est un
risque sur les prix c'est à dire que la
rémunération n'étant pas au rendez-vous
je pense au lait en particulier les
producteurs décident de ne plus vendre
ou les transformateurs décident de ne
plus transformer c'est tout le combat
que nous menons au travers des deux lois
qui a eu successivement qui ont eu lieu
qui sont les lois égalim pour faire en
sorte que la rémunération la
rémunération c'est un élément de la
souveraineté si vous ne payez pas
à son juste prix les produits agricoles
et les produits alimentaires à ce
moment-là vous prenez un risque sur
votre souveraineté et de rupture de
chaîne mais ça n'est pas une rupture
liée aux productions primaires c'est une
rupture liée à l'équilibre économique de
ces filières le président de la
République a annoncé en fin de semaine
dernière un plan pour lutter contre les
incendies de forêts qui ont s'en
souvient on fait d'immenses dégâts à
l'été dernier ça passera notamment par
l'augmentation du nombre de Canadair qui
iront enfin il y en aura 16 au lieu de
12 et un certain nombre seront
renouvelés le parc sera rajeuni il sera
également
ennemi de la mise en place est prévue
d'une météo des forêts de quoi va-t-il
s'agir il s'agit de faire en sorte que
nous puissions en permanence connaître
l'état des sols l'état de sécheresse
pour éviter que des départs d'incendie
ne se produisent sans que sans crier
gare si je peux dire c'est à dire de
vérifier l'état hydrique c'est une
méthode scientifique ou l'humain ces
méthodes scientifiques et contre
l'humain mais c'est d'abord mettons
scientifique parce que donner Météo
France sont des données très précieuses
compléter des données parfois d'un
certain nombre d'agents forestiers des
agents de l'ONF ou des agents qui
travaillent dans les forêts privées on a
besoin effectivement de mieux savoir ce
qui se passe en période estivale pour
mieux prévenir c'est un élément de
diagnostic qui permet après de mieux
agir et mieux anticipé parce qu'on sait
que un feu quand il est pris dans le
premier quart d'heure on a de grandes
chances de pouvoir le maîtriser et quand
il est beaucoup plus avancé c'est
beaucoup plus difficile à maîtriser on
l'a vu d'ailleurs cet été merci Marc
Raynaud bonne journée merci à